the greatest Advertiser of Our
Generation David Ogilvy said once you've
written your headline you've spent 80
cents of your advertising Dollar in a
day of Twitter threads YouTube reels
everyone's trying to nail the hook but
most people don't even know how to
define it a hook is the combination of
the topic the headline and the format
that you display your message that
increases the likelihood that someone
will engage with your content if someone
does not want to engage with a hook they
will not read past that or listen or
watch past that all of your attention
should be going towards the first
impression that is ultimately the
biggest lever on how many people will
ultimately consume your stuff